Các bạn thấy cho lúc thấy, lúc tìm lấy mục đình thấy hài, nó có thuộc trường nào trong những trở bởi đồ đâu
Đúng rồi
Đúng rồi, đúng không?
Đúng không?
Cái trò của mình thó này thì còn gì nó không có có phụng nhạc
Lúc tìm lấy mục đồ phụng ál đồ thì nấy hài
Khi đôi trưởng không có bất đồng là một đây này
Em tìm, đúng không?
Em tìm lối nhạc này
Đúng rồi, lúc nhạc, lúc nhạc, lúc nhạc, lúc nhạc, lúc nhạc, lúc nhạc
Lúc lần mà xin là là ngon bây này
Đai
Có hiểu nhạc
Đi hay
Em đang sĩ chuyển từ bởi đẹp có bởi đẹp không?
Đó chính là
Học em hay lòng xong
Nó mối
Để giờ
Sau của có người thấy
Dọng lúc chảy thằng của người, hướng mới, hướng mới, hướng mới
Hướng mới của em
Mà thân khi em bị dòng lúc của nha, nó sẽ đi tụng chỉ chảm lại
Hướng thực tế là lòng 8 xong là mình lòng lúc bị cháo
Hì nó ở là gió em bị nước
Ròng nước
Rất ở đây, mù này, Rất ở Ròng nước
Trời, từ bắt xuống nha, rất là trời, xong xong của lòng xong
Với hướng nhạc
Hình ra khi đó, bắt xuống nha, mình sẽ bị dòng lúc đầy
Lại nó có đối chuyển qua em, nó sẽ bị cháo xong nha
Đai, có hiểu nhạc
Hôm nay, nó kinh của thấy thành định nhận thêm các bạn, bởi bài dòng hình